hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday what is it August 28th 2017
what's going on yeah what's up
sorry that was obnoxious I understand I
understand but I got to make the ladies
shut it off first right oh my god who is
this guy yelling why would you want to
listen to that when you could just do it
you could just sit and watch reality
television with myself listen to a bunch
of broads [ __ ] yelling at each other
it's unreal it's unreal my wife watches
that [ __ ] all the time all the [ __ ]
time you come home and it's just like
it's like they live with us you know
what I mean me and my wife we get any we
get along great you know but you
wouldn't know it walking up the [ __ ]
front walk to the house you hear like
five women screaming at each other you
know it's just like what are we hosting
the Jerry Springer Show what's going on
you open the door and she's watching The
Real Housewives of who gives a [ __ ] the
Real Housewives of Trenton the Real
Housewives of Dayton Ohio wherever the
hell they are wherever they are whatever
city they're in the Real Housewives they
got fake tits they got big ass [ __ ]
they got ass injection lips they got the
[ __ ] Botox it's unbeliev
Real Housewives Grand Rapids you like
this not gonna be some Hollywood [ __ ]
guy and there it is why is everybody
walking around acting like there's some
aging actress you know what I mean and
they somehow they have to look good for
what the what the [ __ ] are you looking
you ever 50 year old mom just be a mom
relax it's over you landed a guy he
knocked you up all the laws are in your
favor for God's sakes go have a [ __ ]
piece of pie and go smoke a camel I
don't understand what the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] spaghetti strapped women you
know the stupid they're still wearing
the tag tops you know what I mean Jesus
Christ with the [ __ ] tired skin
showing what are you doing trying to
compete with you
what are you doing good luck take a page
out of my book just [ __ ] just give in
to it
you have such falling out [ __ ] shave
it your legs are too white put some
pants on your [ __ ] guts getting too
big start wearing sport coats onstage
these are the what this did that's the
classy way
that's the classy way to just gracefully
you know go from being young into you're
middle-aged into just being old that's
what you do then you get an old man hat
right
you start puttering around you make
funny little jokes everybody loud look
at him look at that old guys still
making jokes that's what you do you
don't get chemicals shot into your
[ __ ] face you know and enhance your
[ __ ] tits like what what are you
trying to do huh you're trying to give
some 60 year-old a hard-on I don't
understand what these women are doing it
was funny I didn't even want to talk
about this [ __ ] I just I don't know why
that just came out it just did
alright I had a wonderful show last
night a wonderful show I was at the Cape
Cod melody melody tent if I could say it
which is such a special place for me to
do stand-up because the one and only
time I ever saw the great George Carlin
live was at the Cape Cod melody tent and
I am embarrassed to say I saw him in
1988 and me and this other guy went to
go see him to laugh at him because my
buddy had me convinced that he had
stopped writing and that he was still
doing 20 year old bits so we were gonna
go see him as a joke if you can listen
how [ __ ] stupid I was one of the most
prolific comedians of all [ __ ] time
so we show up to laugh at this guy and
within two seconds we would do just on
the [ __ ] floor laughing and the guy
had his brand-new 90 [ __ ] minutes and
we were driving home like he he wasn't
doing more stuff he wasn't doing [ __ ]
like that's how dumb I was I did a lot
of dumb [ __ ] back then I went to some
comedy shows and I was literally the
person in the crowd
I wasn't hackling or anything you know
what I mean although one time I did
Haeckel don rickles just cuz i wanted to
have an interaction with them and I knew
that I wasn't gonna meet him you know I
saw him at a casino about four years ago
and I waited til his encore and he came
on the encore and he was just doing his
jokes doing his jokes and I was way in
the back he's playing this giant grin
was way in the back and I just went
Donny he didn't say anything kept doing
his jokes kept doing his jokes I waited
like another three minutes I went Darnay
and he just looked out to where I was
sitting he goes yeah I know my name made
that [ __ ] Rickles face and I was with
Bartnik and he [ __ ] elbowed he cause
he heard you he heard and that was it
you know I broke a major rule of
engagement there with the [ __ ] as a
stand-up comedian I should have done it
but I I couldn't help myself I could
have helped myself you know what let's
be honest why don't we just be honest
okay now that that stupid [ __ ] fight
is over can we all just be honest with
ourselves here I'm a selfish person and
rather than accepting the fact that I
wasn't gonna get an interaction with
them I had to do that because I'm a
selfish [ __ ] okay and you know now can
we all be honest about what went on
Saturday night I gotta be honest with
you I have not even seen highlights of
it I didn't [ __ ] watch it I actually
came home and was staying with some
relatives here in Boston who also didn't
get the fight because there's sane
people there like yeah it's just you
know he's Floyd's gonna carry him for a
couple of rounds that he's gonna finish
him and then they're both you know
they're not gonna really [ __ ] each other
up they're both gonna leave with a
boatload of money isn't that what's
going on here yeah is there some guy
Alvarez who's actually a [ __ ]
modern-day champion or some [ __ ] like
that coming up and well we'll spend the
money on that we'll spend the money on
that [ __ ] thing whatever that boxing
match I don't know [ __ ] about boxing but
I do know Lyle Alzado verse Muhammad Ali
when I [ __ ] see it so I mean a better
version of it I should say but anyways
we actually watched wicked tuna I have
such mixed emotions when I watch those
fishing shows you know I got this lovely
animals but I also love tuna you know
I'm an environmentalist who loves crab
you know king-crab who the [ __ ] doesn't
love that that's just [ __ ] tremendous
so when they're sitting there talking
about how it's all fished out and they
can't find any and that type of stuff
you know it's not that we should stop
crabbing this should just be less
[ __ ] people that they have to find it
for you know so you know I don't know I
always have all these [ __ ] ideas of
how to you know trim down the population
and of course I'm never part of the
problem right as those as most mass
murdering maniacs you're never part of
the problem like Hitler I'm sure when he
looked in the window the window looked
in the mirror right and was brushing his
[ __ ] teeth right I'm sure that he saw
a blonde haired blue eyed person instead
of seeing what he truly was which was
the runt of the litter
you know enemy but the guy had heart and
he [ __ ] overcame what the [ __ ] he
looked like to achieve his dream you
know granted he was out of his [ __ ]
mind but I mean that alone should have
just C should have been if he wasn't so
crazy would have been we'll look at me
I'm [ __ ] ugly as [ __ ] and look what
I've achieved you know what if somebody
who looks like me actually had a good
heart imagine what they would achieve
isn't that why I [ __ ] alone a ticket
well I'm a [ __ ] lunatic is that guy
there like you know my dream came true
and I played the Cape Cod melody tent
telling jokes his dream came true
and [ __ ] you know tens of millions of
people died that was literally his dream
you know like imagine if he never did
his [ __ ] right and he just lived a
regular life and then all of a sudden
God for black eggs did god forbid it's
him I just naturally say god forbid when
I talk about terminal disease Adolf
Hitler right doesn't [ __ ] you know
somebody bought his paintings or some
[ __ ] right so he just doesn't go down
that [ __ ] road
now he's just you know some regular guy
and and then he has like he gets some
terminal illness and for some reason
make-a-wish is back then and they go
what what is your dream what is your
wish and then he's good and then eg
rarely
to make my wish come true this is what
we do 8:00 off we make sure you die with
a smile on your face what is your dream
and he would have laid there you know
telling the guy to come a little bit
closer what do you want to do I would to
exterminate all of the Jews that's what
he would have said and what a [ __ ]
quagmire that make-a-wish would have
been in no they would have had to have
they would have to a hang on a second
they'd have to step out in the hall go
and I what are we doing I mean well you
know I mean we just kind of made a broad
statement that we make dreams come true
we didn't clarify it like oh we want to
stand out here long enough maybe he'll
[ __ ] die the disease I mean our old
reputations on the line right and then
all of a sudden make-a-wish gets dragged
into it gets dragged into the madness of
this man and then no longer looked upon
there's this wonderful organization that
they are right which takes in millions
and millions of dollars right and God
knows what the [ __ ] they do who knows
you never know what those charities
right are they helping people up or they
helping themselves to a classic Camaro
with some tea tubs when we return we'll
be taking some calls sorry I don't what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about today so
anyways yeah everybody thought I was
gonna cave I did I have not caved on two
fronts
I have not drank in 11 days and I feel
right this is it dude I go 11 days I
could go a year I could go a [ __ ]
year I feel [ __ ] fantastic and I just
used the word fantastic I never
fantastic
you know I'm doing cardio like I've
always been doing but I'm not negating
it at night with the [ __ ] three or
four a home pool is over there with the
giant ice cube and it's actually the
sober life is [ __ ] great it just
sucks at night it's the only thing at
night it sucks at night you know because
it's like what the [ __ ] do I do I'm like
yeah I like I'm a habbit guy so this is
the time of night I [ __ ] do this and
then I'm not doing it I'm like well now
what do i do what do I do so you know I
did I start playing guitar again
anything you know I suck what do you
want I mean just I go in there I [ __ ]
play a little
during that time then it gets late and
then I'd literally feel my body just
going to come on doing Gopal won't go
that's right over there look at the
bottom dude look at the bottle it's my
dad just bought yourself one and I just
all have to do is just go downstairs to
my bedroom and then the fact that I'm an
old man takes over like I do it I am NOT
[ __ ] going all the way back up there
he's animal easy
even as I'm laying there you know yeah I
go downstairs and my angel of a wife is
laying in bed watching five women she
doesn't know scream at each other and
say horrible things you know they're
really big on attacking like if a
woman's never had a child they're really
big on attacking that I found out man it
[ __ ] mean just me goddamn [ __ ]
mean people you know it's dumbest guys
are the way we solve [ __ ] with violence
I just think you know just punching
somebody in the face is way more civil
than saying well that's why you're
barren and you can't have a child it's
like really do me a favor next time just
punch me in the nose wouldn't it just be
can we just can we just leave it at that
so there's something to salvage
afterwards Jesus Christ so many but now
that I've gone 11 days now it's it just
starts to fade like I don't even I mean
I walk by my [ __ ] I told you 1927
Yankees lineup worth the [ __ ] booze
and I'm telling you like I don't even
see it anymore like you know I don't I
don't I don't I get murderers row
murderers row the [ __ ] that I drink you
know and they're all I have the batting
order you know what I mean top of the
order right through cleanup is the top
of the shelf top shelf [ __ ] you know
that's your Pappy's I say okay here we
go let's go with booze so what would you
line up be who's hitting leadoff who's
getting on base right who's your [ __ ]
Rickey Henderson that's gonna [ __ ]
possibly hit a solo shot and the next
guys don't even have to knock him in you
know what I'm gonna say I'm gonna go
Rickey Henderson is Johnny Walker Blue
ok this is gonna be hard I got too many
cleanup hitters then I would say bat and
second is grand patron all right I'm not
a big tequila guy so I'm not getting
into that [ __ ] agave [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] they put in it then I would say
this is a hard one I would say maybe
some Pappy Van Winkle's is going third
then bat and cleanup in my world I would
say is McCallum rare cask right now
we're getting to the middle of the order
this is you know it's not a special
occasion I just want to get [ __ ] up
all right
these are the guys hitting 270 280 then
you get the middle order you got Johnnie
Walker Black is batting fifth I'd say no
fifth is patron silver Johnny Walker
Black is batting sixth batting seventh
eighth and ninth now you're talking
companies coming over you like these
people but they don't they don't like
appreciate good booze so you're just
gonna hit him with some basic [ __ ] right
that's when you have to go makers mark
Jack Daniels batting ninth batting ninth
if someone wants to mix it I'll give you
this is the [ __ ] this is this is the
national league when the pitcher bats
Johnny Walker red label there you go
that's my life dad you know what semi
and you booze lineups probably should've
had a bag I can do the beer one lead off
Scott to be Budweiser you know that
thing's getting on [ __ ] pace right
that second I would have Miller High
Life batting third
no no let me I'm gonna be a [ __ ] I gotta
lead off Coors Light no but we're doing
best beer all the way down nah no no
what am I doing here what am I doing
here all right
I'm I'm I am white trash when it comes
to beer okay
the fanciest I mean alcohol I would say
echo Budweiser then Miller High Life
then I'd say batting third batting third
and beer as a tough one you start wanted
people clear the bases a little bit I'll
go a little snobby and I will say blue
moon I don't mind the orange slice
I don't mind it like I find what if I'm
just [ __ ] thirsty I'll have one of
those bat and clean up is Guinness all
right then I have a black and tan fifth
six now you just get now you want to get
[ __ ] up right but you don't want to
get your [ __ ] inner become a fat [ __ ]
so I would say Coors Light light beer
famila now eight and nine eight and nine
this is for when some you know some
older people are coming over with their
kids and you just get a [ __ ] I don't
know for whatever [ __ ] reason you got
to have an IPA and one of those others
like a Sierra Nevada or some [ __ ] I
would something like that I don't drink
but I mean I'd leave that alone
I said is mrs. stupidest converse I'm
literally [ __ ] sober and I'm making
booze batting lineups all right now if
you're a beer drinker if you're a hard
liquor you know I want to hear your
lineups okay let's get ready manned up
the [ __ ] pennant races are heating up
all right I want to I want to see what
your lineups are you come walking up to
the bar with your little pulling your
mitt you [ __ ] lineup card out of your
back pocket
by the way that blue moon is signed to
like a one-year contract you know you
know you just pick up a [ __ ] big bat
at the end of the [ __ ] season like he
did you know he's not he's not a true
red sock
all right so anyways by the way somebody
tweeted at me that stupid company out
there and [ __ ] Wisconsin it
microchipping their [ __ ] employees
and these [ __ ] idiots are doing it
and you know and I'm like why would they
do that and then all you have to do is
look at their faces and you look at them
they I have this childlike innocence
they they're believers that's all it is
they grew up in a great state of
Wisconsin where you're sheltered all
right you're in the Midwest you're in
that heart of the country that fat
[ __ ] weasel in North Korea his
missiles even if it makes it that far
he's not shooting it at Wisconsin right
the Green Bay Packers do they're like
owned by the fans it's [ __ ]
everybody's making cheez-its Maybury you
ever been to Wisconsin it's [ __ ]
tremendous the air is fresh
the water is [ __ ] clean at least it
looks that way when I Drive by at 80
miles an hour under way do some
godforsaken [ __ ] place I'm gonna
perform at right it's tremendous [ __ ]
these people they believe right they all
ordered to fight they think he's gonna
make it great again they chase they
believe you know why because they're
[ __ ] good people out there so they
walk into the work they hey guys this is
the new thing and they and they sit
there looking gee I don't know this
seems a little bit creepy right but how
did they get them and how do you get how
do you get the general masses how do you
get them all right there's two ways to
get the general masses fear and free
t-shirts one or the other
you scare the [ __ ] out of them they're
[ __ ] on board you tell them the
boogeyman is under that bed whatever the
[ __ ] you tell them they need to do
they're gonna [ __ ] do it if you don't
want to [ __ ] waste your time coming
up some [ __ ] boogeyman story just
make a free [ __ ] t-shirt and that's
what they did in Wisconsin they had
these [ __ ] t-shirts that said I got
chipped that was it that was that was
the tipping point
wait a minute if I put that foreign
object in me that I have no idea what it
is no idea what its capabilities are no
idea what it really does other than what
you tell me you evil [ __ ] you'll give me
that free t-shirt and you know they got
on me extra soft once oh my god dude my
I tell you right now my favorite my
favorite go-to t-shirt is my I got
chipped it's so soft you know then as
much as I'm making fun of them I see the
writing on the wall because there's way
more people there's way more believers
out there you know believing in the
invisible lines believing in the team's
believing in all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
right believe in it they're evil but
these people are Saints or vice versa
right these people are either do it they
do it all over the world God loves us
best these people are infidels these
people are [ __ ] there's these people
are [ __ ] that it's the thing is the
common thread with human beings is that
this [ __ ] lunatics at the top okay
and then you have nice people at the
bottom you know Wisconsin people people
give this shirt off you [ __ ] back you
know provided you not to ten let's let's
not let's not overly romanticize these
white people the end of day they are
white people okay and I'm not [ __ ]
on my own people but just in a position
it's this society my way you know
nobody's watching us so we get to go
full [ __ ] you know full [ __ ]
frontal nudity with their [ __ ] brains
there's nobody there's nobody in that
way right that's why we that's why we go
[ __ ] crazy you need some sort of hand
on maybe that's what the microchip is
for I have no idea I just know at the
end of the [ __ ] trail who is it think
of some of the people that run [ __ ] look
at Bill Clinton the man could not keep
his dick in his pants he shoving cigars
up women's vaginas half his [ __ ] age
that [ __ ] guy that that's one of the
guys run [ __ ] or someone of his [ __ ]
ilk you gonna let that guy put a [ __ ]
microchip what do I get a free t-shirt
yes you don't Skippy all right
and that's it this is the thing they
don't need they don't need thinking
people to buy in all they need is the
free t-shirt people and the free t-shirt
people you get enough of them it becomes
a tipping point and then they can start
changing you know what I mean it's like
the toll booths right everybody easy
pass I'm not getting that you're not
gonna [ __ ] track where I'm going all
right there was just one easy pass Lane
ten [ __ ] lanes will you through your
changing or [ __ ] went to a guy right
and then it became eight seven six five
four three two one go [ __ ] yourself well
you don't have to you can use the
[ __ ] surface roads you don't have to
use the highways but your taxes did pay
for them then you like [ __ ] that's what
happens and they'll get all of us you
know what you know what I love about
life though they can never stop you from
drinking yourself to death and that's
one to grow on
alright with that let's uh I'm sorry
that guy that got really [ __ ] darker
alright what are we doing here live
Reed's okay I'm reading off my phone
here because I have no internet where
I'm at right now I'm gonna have to go
drive down to a [ __ ] coffee shop you
know there's nothing in a coffee shop
that I want other than their internet
you know I don't drink coffee your your
little pastries are there like eating a
[ __ ] bathroom tile they're always
[ __ ] up they just suck everything in
Starbucks [ __ ] sucks I don't I don't
have the coffee I know the coffee is
there heroin all right but you ever go
into a bodega that's really selling
[ __ ] drugs you don't I mean you know
like oldest cereal is that's what that's
like what [ __ ] like Starbucks is it's
like a drug deal in bodega you don't I
mean and like the only thing that that
that is good in there that is that is
not past it's [ __ ] date of freshness
is the [ __ ] drugs that they sell and
with Starbucks it's the coffee
everything else in this sucks
that's why you gotta love Dunkin Donuts
you know their coffee evidently is out
of this [ __ ] world but they also make
they make these great donuts alright
draftkings everybody fantasy for oh [ __ ]
draftkings is back I love these guys cuz
they finally admitted what the [ __ ] they
were doing alright alright she [ __ ]
degenerate game
but there you go you're in a loveless
marriage let's add to the pain
draftkings fantasy football season is
almost here and there's no better way to
get closer to the game you love than to
put your [ __ ] paycheck on it with
draftkings one-week fantasy football
draft Kings is hosting a $100,000
contest
that is totally free to enter all you
have to do is put you a paycheck down
and if you and if you don't draft the
perfect lineup you can what and if you
draft the perfect lineup you can win one
billion dollars all right I was making
fun of this now I think I'm in with
draft kings there are many ways to play
choose between public contests with big
cash prizes or private contests where
you can compete against a group of your
friends
draftkings also has a beginner and
casual contest where you play against
people of a similar skill level that's
like when the drug dealer gives you a
free tastes the best part is you get to
draft a new team each week without any
commitment so to get draft kings.com now
and use so get draft kings.com now and
use promo code Burpee URR to play a
draft king free week one contest with a
hundred thousand dollars in total prizes
and if yes these guys are brilliant and
if you don't if you draft the perfect
lineup you can win 1 billion dollars I
don't know what the perfect lineup is
use my promo code burr to play for free
and week 1 that's promo code burr at
draft kings.com eligibility restrictions
apply
see draft kings.com for details I love
that they're back in the ring I would I
want to I want to see that movie get
made how they came about how quickly
they grew and now quickly at the state
and federal level they're like wait a
minute this is a national drought
gambling ring and we're not getting any
[ __ ] money out of this how many beats
did you have to [ __ ] wet to get back
into the game Jesus I bet they went to
one of those Bilderberg makes alright he
like started he likes everybody Alex I
don't what the [ __ ] this is I you're
you're unique oh you're a special person
are you you don't walk like everyone
else talk like everyone else
chat or anything anyone else are sleep
like anyone else so why the [ __ ] is your
mattress one-size-fits-all no no because
it's a basic shape to everybody because
a truly customized mattress will cost
you five to ten thousand bucks and oh
there's the answer right there until now
go to helix sleep calm and answer a few
simple questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model of your body through
their proprietary algorithms they
developed with the help of the world's
leading ear economics and biomechanics
experts Jesus Christ what his sentence
the result the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on HELOCs customers
report a 30% improvement in overall
sleep quality and for couples they
customize each side of the mattress is
the beginning of the end of the
relationship your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 100% free I like mine to be like this
yeah I like it to be like that I'd
rather [ __ ] this guy don't give a [ __ ]
I'm already banging her helix sleep
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about HELOCs
sleep you have 100 nights to try it out
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free
gross and give you a 100% refund no
questions asked be funny if they asked
you what was the problem well I mean
sleeping was okay but I went to bang my
wife I kept getting this pain in my left
knee yeah you know I played sports but I
you know I never had painted that one
look my [ __ ] knee hurts when I banged
my wife I don't what to tell you all
right I'll sign them all right go to
hell it's sleep calm slash bar and get
$50 off your order that's helix sleep
calm slash bar hey hello sleep compr h e
li x oh Jesus look who's back movement
watches everyone hang in there I got two
more here movement watches you guys no
movement right they reinvented the watch
business by selling directly to you with
over 1 million watches sold to date
well you goddamn it these bastards did
it again except this time with
sunglasses now you thought they were
done with watches now they're gonna keep
going they just shot one right across
the bow of every design
[ __ ] sunglass boat out there they
were tired of having to paint they were
tired of having to pay for cheaply made
throwaway shades or overpriced designer
glasses so they said [ __ ] they
actually wrote screw it they said [ __ ]
it you know that's what they said in the
meeting we'll make our own starting at
just 77 T dollars with the option to
upgrade to polarized with over what if
[ __ ] does that mean
polarized you stop agreeing with people
ii like you [ __ ] he's a polarizing
character those overpriced designer
brands will will run you upwards of 200
bucks movement figured out by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup providing
the best possible prices they figure
this out with watches they like hey why
not do it with I'm glad you I hope they
keep going we've done it again we've cut
out the middleman with [ __ ] dildos
where they are high quality premium I
don't know how to say it's a CET eighty
a state acetate eat eight frames no
cheap plastic hair you gotta see these
they have a lot of styles to choose from
classy trendy round aviator married
polarized you know if I had internet I'd
looked at a polarized sunglasses what
the [ __ ] does that mean you wear him
down in Antarctica for him and for her
you're sure to find the perfect pair get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to movement calm
slash / you know movement for how
they've revolutionized the watch
industry now is the time to check out
this sunglasses go to nvm t.com slash
burr join the movement
alright last one oh god why is this copy
so long just get to the [ __ ] point
wink winc for some reason pronounced
wink when you have a great glass of wine
it enhances the moment whether you're
reflecting on it-- you know if i had to
make a wine line-up this is what it
would be whose lead enough you gotta
kill lead off
the cat eye man you [ __ ] bottom of
the order I don't know who the [ __ ] you
I would all I know is a borough Lowe's
batting cleanup for me and I don't give
a [ __ ] about anything else about why you
know what I mean I take on the whole
wine world with just the two of those
nice [ __ ] cap if I want to get
shit-faced Barolo if I don't know if I
did something that day all right when
you have a great glass of wine it
enhances the moment whether you're
reflecting on the day or with someone
you love
wink understands this it's why they
started their company I mean how many
times we have to tell you this is why
they [ __ ] did it to give you access
to exceptional wines from around the
world so you can have more of these
moments see I need to use it well if I
wasn't on the wagon I'd use this [ __ ]
because I cause if you can't put
together a nine [ __ ] bottle list of
booze beer or wine I guess liquor I
should say then then you know you're
really doing your liver a disservice
just try winked calm t ry winc calm take
a brief pallet profile quiz and you know
and somehow that'll end up on somebody's
microchip and their [ __ ] hand in
Wisconsin and wink will recommend
distinct and interesting wines actually
customized to your palate to be shipped
directly to your door every month none
of your time is what you'd be funny if
you committed a murder years later you
left the [ __ ] wine glass and they
went back to this information well it
says here that that wine glass was part
of your profile is that not true it's
part of your palate profile then you get
all nervous you just confess to it on
the stand right like think it's the
1950s cop show they were tired of having
to pay for cheaply made throwaway wait
that's the shades we like what did I do
here none of your time is wasted fitting
in a run to the store or your way home
from work or your way to an event or a
gathering no more time spent guessing
what you might like because wink bases
the wines they send you on your taste
preferences wink will even introduce you
to new rare custom wines that are not
available anywhere else and tell you the
story behind each one no membership fees
skip any month cancel anytime and wink
has a 100% satisfaction guaranteed so
you never pay for a bottle you don't
like and right now wink is offering
listeners $20 off your first order when
you go try go to try wink calm / /
that's try wink spelled T ry winc calm /
bar to get $20 off your first order now
try wink calm / bar there you go oh
thank god it's [ __ ] over
thank God it's [ __ ] over now Jesus
Christ you know one thing I do like
about technique technology I like
DocuSign I really enjoy that [ __ ] makes
it nice and [ __ ] easy oh by the way I
have to hide this gig because they don't
do a lot of they don't do a lot of
stand-up at this venue now at this point
if you listen to the podcast for a while
now you realize that you know as much as
old freckles goes onstage telling jokes
he's actually a frustrated musician you
know I wish I was good at guitar I wish
I was good at Trump's I have a
tremendous amount of respect the
musicians speaking of which Queens of
the Stone Age one of my favorite bands
of all time
put out their brand-new album this week
I'm gonna be listening to it and I'll
give you my own review of it on Thursday
just kidding I [ __ ] hate when people
do that like I'm supposed to listen to
you who the [ __ ] are you you know
[ __ ] listen to you I'll listen to it
myself and make up my own mind how about
that how about that all right there you
took person you to person anyways I'm
gonna be November 2nd I'm gonna be in
Clear Lake Iowa at the Surf ballroom
you know the Surf ballroom is the that's
the last place Buddy Holly the Big
Bopper Ritchie Valens all of those guys
played Waylon Jennings was there that
night and he went on the bus and
everything just being a music fan I
don't know it's slightly morbid to play
there but I'm gonna play there and I'm
flying in I'm landing at the [ __ ]
airport they took off from everything
dude aren't you [ __ ] nervous they
crash because there was no de-icing
technology back then they had too much
weight on their wings which changed the
shape of the airfoil they were
overweight they couldn't [ __ ] produce
enough lift they crashed and they died
that's not going to happen in 2017 so
I'm gonna be there what happened to me
won't happen to you if you want to check
out this legendary venue November 2nd
Clear Lake Iowa Surf ballroom I'm gonna
be there with Dean Delray who was
actually born the same day that they all
died not the same year but the same day
so it's gonna be that's gonna be
tremendously freaky [ __ ] night I got
a brand new hour and last night I it
could not have gone better and I left
out half of my [ __ ] jokes I was
having so much fun down at the Cape Cod
Mele detent so please get your tickets
November 2nd Clear Lake Iowa the Surf
ballroom and I will be tweeting out and
facebooking out a link because I am an
old man I'm not on Photoshop I'm not on
Instagram it's not Photoshop what's the
other one in this Instagram and then
there's the other one
snapchat I need to get on those right is
that what I need to do by the way I'm
thinking of putting together a college
tour a tour of colleges in the beginning
of next year to help promote f is for
family and bringing a bunch of swag to
you know free merchandise free f is for
family merchandise this is what I want
to do if I get enough interest from
certain schools especially the
University of Kansas when the Jayhawks
have a home basketball game so I can go
to that legendary arena that would be
tremendous do you understand what I'm
saying here I was actually thinking of
doing that once a year right and every
like you know college [ __ ] Division
you know like one year I'll do a big ten
[ __ ] F is family tour I'll do an SEC
one I'll do a pac-12 whatever the [ __ ]
that called now the WAC right do
something like that I don't know I'm
always thinking of [ __ ] ideas like
that [ __ ] but just to help promote it
and maybe cuz that's my [ __ ] jump I
gotta sell the goddamn shovel don't get
mad at me alright alright 37 minutes in
here we go here we go alright let's
let's read some of your questions here
for this week
buh buh buh buh buh boom the 90s dear
Billy temple pilot I'm feeling a bit
nostalgic for the 90s I was 12 and 1990
ten years older than you you bastard and
had no stress or responsibilities I get
how that influences this but it was a
good time I'm happy with technology now
in our society is more conscious of
social issues but everything is so loud
now do you ever get nostalgic for the
90s if so what part of the 90s can you
have your podcast guy use the friends
theme song for the Thursday podcast
that's a question mark do or anything
awesome from the 90s thanks for reading
this if you do life is pretty boring
these days and if I could you use
something to brighten my day as a pet
store manager all right sir
here's what's happening to you is you're
slipping into your life and you don't
like what's going on
so rather than fixing the now you're
going back in time that's not I mean
that's that's a temporary fix okay if
you don't want to manage a pet store ask
yourself what you really want to do and
start slowly walking towards that taking
a half a step a quarter step every day
and one point you're gonna look up and
goddamnit there it is just like Indiana
Jones and then you grab it and all of a
sudden a giant ball starts rolling after
you and you gotta [ __ ] run out of
there and that's you after you make it
then trying to stay there all right but
that's way more exciting than managing
this pet store that you know you're
saying brighten your day
as a pet store manager you one of these
guys who actually doesn't like animals
you probably don't like the people right
coming in there whatever I don't know
what did this but it's but it I will
answer your question my favorite part of
the 90s was the month before
nevermind came out and I was listening
to the Skid Row's slave to the grind
and I thought hair metal and all night
wasn't a hair metal but metal was never
gonna end because that was doing what
you loved was the end of my youth
because I was 22 in 1990 so that was the
end of the end of it for me so like
think about 2004 you you're getting out
of college all this new musics coming
out you're starting to not be able to
you know the next few years you can't
keep up with it what the [ __ ] are they
listening to and then that's what
happens and then
you start driving around but I'm not
gonna let you do this [ __ ] that I still
listen to you know I try to listen to
newer [ __ ] like you know it's a new band
at me like Cold War Kids and I'm like I
saw them you know recently they're on TV
I'll download some of this stuff and I'm
like I remember that song that [ __ ]
ball bat mantis on that [ __ ] soon the
guys singing away the really high voice
amazing voice and I was looking intense
like that [ __ ] album came out 2006 or
something
so I'm way behind the curve but I try to
stay up on all right you want to hear
some embarrassing I'm gonna [ __ ] tell
you all my latest my latest downloads I
downloaded Dream Weaver by Gary Wright
that album tremendously tremendously
[ __ ] underrated album all right
because everybody thinks of they think
of that song Dream Weaver right and
everybody laughs at that song you know
they use it in these ironic history
hipster [ __ ] ways I gotta tell you
man that [ __ ] album is the [ __ ] and
this stuff is some poppy [ __ ] on there
but all these years of me talking about
loving to play drums and all this stuff
why didn't nobody tell me about Andy
Newmark Jesus Christ that guy's one of
the best [ __ ] drummers I've ever
heard he plays on this album and you
know you don't have to get it for
[ __ ] Dream Weaver or any of that [ __ ]
but like love is alive for the longest
time I thought that sounded like Clapton
to me singing oh maybe like one of those
Steve Winwood bands just listens to how
tasty the [ __ ] drums are and I'll
actually post a video this week of him
[ __ ] playing with like Rod Stewart
and these guys just [ __ ] wailing
alright so he downloaded that then I
downloaded Cold War Kids robbers and
cowards I'm downloading the new Queens
of the Stone Age today and then here's
well Jesus well he's in defense of me I
lost a lot of my music when I dropped my
last phone into the toilet it was
actually in my back pocket
and I stood up from taking taking a dump
right no no I didn't I didn't I was
[ __ ] hammered I remember this guy was
saying there was something about
standing up when you take a piss some
[ __ ] health reason so I sat down like
a lady right and I had my phone in my
back pocket when I stood up and [ __ ]
fell into the toilet
[ __ ] brutal like I was gonna go get
that now it ain't happening so I don't
use the cloud and everything just I lost
everything so I downloaded ac/dc if you
want blood you got it live ac/dc for
those about to rock a CDC high voltage
then I had to get my vintage Aerosmith
and there I downloaded get your wings
Rox Toys in the Attic
then I downloaded the new [ __ ] mute
math while I'm on waiting I'm still
waiting for the rest of that album come
out to play dead I downloaded Glen
Campbell Rhinestone Cowboy because I've
been singing that with the advertising
like a rat's toe ball bag Peter Frampton
Frampton Comes Alive all J's all J this
is all yours Marvin Gaye sexual healing
download what a [ __ ] tremendous song
that is the new royal blood album
Anthony Hamilton then I downloaded like
three prints albums no two of them sign
of the times and then dirty mine
the first Soundgarden album the Prince
album for you then a Dave Brubeck live
at Carnegie Hall then a bunch of Miles
Davis that's what I've done in the last
couple of months steaming with Miles
working with miles round about midnight
relaxing with Miles cooking with Miles
and there you go that's what the [ __ ]
had been downloaded what else do I got
to get Wayne Shorter the idiot King
attention-deficit I think that's a oh
that's what's-his-face Tim Alexander on
drums on that the brown album
Badmotorfinger Temple of the dog oh that
was right when Chris Cornell died I had
to get all that [ __ ] music
back up my phone John Coltrane's Sonny
Rollins Tesla skid-row there you go
Marilyn Manson Primus Primus Primus
animals should not act like people pork
Soto and sailing the Seas of cheese you
know what DeRosa just sent me a new
[ __ ] they knew their latest [ __ ]
track it's the [ __ ] I absolutely loved
it
Primus has a new one coming out what the
[ __ ] is it called let me see here where
is it where is it where is it in my
phone in my phone in my phone alright
what do I have him underneath it you
know everybody says Joe has no shoulders
that's not true he lacks the meat that
is between your neck and your shoulders
basically is trapezius he was born
without it
alright Primus the seven check that out
this week alright enough with this old
man telling you the music that he likes
let's get back to your young people
questions here shall we
so yeah when grunge came in I got up I
didn't like the first like when Pearl
Jam first came out Nirvana first came
out I didn't like those bands because
they knocked all my bands off the top
ten you know I was like this isn't a
good band what about Britney Foxx
what about winger man what about warrant
yeah I listen I didn't necessary that
was bad music I was young I didn't
[ __ ] know any better you know at
least those guys could [ __ ] play
under these [ __ ] today with a [ __ ]
laptop and a goddamn Christmas tree in
their head so it took me a long time to
admit that Nirvana Pearl Jam were great
bands but like Soundgarden and [ __ ]
Alice in Chains had like [ __ ] that
anger in there and just the sound of
their lead singers man I just I really
like their frontman and now of course
you know I love Pearl Jam I love Nirvana
and all that [ __ ] but I was a bit of a
baby when their music came out I was I
was too young
this is the first time I was seen my
music go away so I wasn't mature enough
to be like you know what you know I I
have to accept that you know my time has
come and gone and that this is what the
[ __ ] music is now and I should listen
to it it took me a good 20 years to be
able to do that alright hey there Billy
Clinton did you did you hear this yet
the court ruled that
head of the Democratic National
Convention debet Wasserman that's her
name
di BB IT Schultz rigged the primaries
against Bernie Sanders the court what
court so this woman under the influence
of Hillary Clinton's camp tampered in
the u.s. election process but none of
the Democrats are celebrity due rights
are going to be outraged because there's
sanctimonious asshats and for the record
I was a registered Democrat and stop
[ __ ] saying that if it's a fact it's
a fact I don't need to you know I used
to be this or I actually voted for Obama
I don't give a [ __ ] what you did if what
you're saying is factual I don't need to
know what the [ __ ] you did I was a
registered Democrat to about 2010 but
with the exception of Bush and Gerald
Ford anyways the hypocrisy is just so
insane to me to not be mad at this
especially as a Democrat I think you
have to have clinical issues yeah well I
heard like Bernie Sanders was drawn a
bunch of people and he just didn't even
cover it all right now where does this
coming from this is the the observer
dot-com June 2016 a class-action suit
was filed against the Democratic
National Committee and the former
Democratic National it's debbie debbie
Wasserman Schultz for violating the DNC
Charter by rigging the Democratic
presidential primaries for Hillary
Clinton against Bernie Sanders Howell
arias would be this big that's actually
doubly sad if this is true even former
Senate Minority Leader Harry Reid
admitted in July 2016 I knew everybody
knew that this was not a fair deal he
added that debbie Wasserman Schultz
should have resigned much sooner than
she did the lawsuit was filed to push
the Democratic National Convention to
admit their wrongdoing and provide
Bernie Sanders supporters who supported
him financial millions of dollars in
campaign contributions with restitution
for being cheated on August 25th 2017
federal judge Williams slice assault
route dismissed the lawsuit after
several months of litigation during
which the Democratic
conventions attorneys argued that the
DNC would be with well within their
rights to rigged primaries and select
their own candidates that was their
arguments so they weren't denying it in
evaluating plaintiffs claims that this
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
send this to Jimmy Dore and I wanted to
because he you know I'm too stupid to be
able to debunk this or say that it's
actually [ __ ] true I want to know I
want to know what love is I mean this
wouldn't surprise me you know what I
mean I would actually love if this got
some [ __ ] attention just to truly
shut up all these [ __ ] dopes in
Hollywood you know you know back in the
day yeah I mean I guess I I mean I I
think that I mean was kid no I'm not
trying to be the spokesperson for
[ __ ] Wesson oil or whatever the [ __ ]
people are trying to do out there but
like I try to like evenly trash
everybody and I'm totally into
conspiracy theory like none of this is
shocking to me you know I just think
we're just inherently flawed and I base
that on myself as I [ __ ] you know as
I just [ __ ] up all the time we just what
just inherently flawed people all right
Jimmy door there we go this is how dumb
I am I'm gonna send this to him and I'm
just gonna text is this true you know
and he loves me enough to actually reply
to this I know part of him is gonna feel
sad that I'm as dumb as I am and then I
have his phone number yeah I mean none
of that surprises me I mean it was he
kind of felt that Bernie was getting
boxed out and I guess maybe the
Democratic National Committee does have
the I guess does have the right to do it
the same way the NFL had the right to
suspend Tom Brady whether he did
anything or not I mean when they took it
to court they go yeah this is [ __ ]
you don't have enough [ __ ] evidence
and they're like well we're a
corporation right does it cooperation
have a right to suspend it to play yes
you do well
brainy's our employee therefore he
suspended that's kind of like what they
did to Bernie Sanders and yes I did just
compare him to Tom Brady I think they
have a lot in common living in a
retirement community at 33 years of age
what's up freckled ball Bank a friend
recently turned me on to your podcast
it's hilarious well thank you thank you
for preventing me from killing myself on
my one hour commute to work well that's
great I like to do what I can
although I am into population maybe I
should take a control population control
maybe should take a couple weeks off my
wife twenty-eight and I 33 finally had
enough money to buy our first home dude
you guys are crushing it so he purchased
a nice little town house in Connecticut
we didn't know at the time but we were
moving into a community that is
potentially the evil offspring of a
retirement village and the House of Wax
oh yeah well that's what happens when
you buy your first house you're so
excited you don't drive around you don't
know the questions to ask now you know
are the people old as [ __ ] around here
just out of curiosity is this a
drug-filled
neighborhood is there any chemical
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the water what are the
schools like you know all those
questions you have to ask all right we
are nice courteous people and so we
think or so we think he's so don't take
the anger in this email out of context
well you have a little perspective that
we use if you said we're nice courtesy
people courteous people but but the fact
that you actually have the intelligence
to say or so we think
understanding that there is another
perspective in life other than your own
we've helped some of our old ass
neighbors carry [ __ ] you know because
they can't with the osteoporosis and
everything we wave and chat with them
when walking our dog and we even hold
the charity beer pong tournament in New
York City every year to raise money for
MS unrelated to our community but shows
we care question mark I guess question
mark anywho enough about us this past
weekend we had my brother and
sister-in-law in town and invited
another couple over on Saturday
Hey sorry if I blew your eardrums out I
tried to pull it away enough I don't
think I took it away in time sorry we
went to hang out at school at us at our
pool sorry we took a float snacks a
couple of beers and a speaker there were
five to seven other people at the pool
all in there hundreds it did not look
like the pool scene from Caddyshack
we hung out chatted sipped a beer and
listened on low to Jack Johnson or some
other mellow soft [ __ ] Monday morning at
10:00 a.m. the entire community got this
email residence it was reported to the
board and the management that over this
past weekend there was some owners and
guests who behaved inappropriately loud
and shouting conversations foul language
and may have partaken in alcoholic
beverages prior to or while visiting the
pool none of these things are acceptable
and are also violation of the pool rules
of the old [ __ ] court obviously you
added that if if said individuals were
seen behaving in such a manner going
forward the police may be called and
said individuals will not be permitted
to use the facilities and may also be
subject to a hearing in front of the
board whereby fines may be imposed the
pool facility is for the peaceful
enjoyment of all residents and we hope
to keep it that way thank you signed the
old-ass Board of Directors Jesus Christ
dude what the you can realize you
[ __ ] bought a house in a retirement
community says first off let me say I've
had I had nothing against the elderly I
love my grandparents it's you don't have
to stop establishing credibility you
bought a [ __ ] house is about you and
the it's like the movie cocoon but if
you jump in the pool you still [ __ ]
old I get it
anyways I called it once a week I enjoy
quieting that in the couch with some
scotch or an old-fashioned and [ __ ] I
still use hotmail yes we're a part of
HOA and in rules above above about
alcohol drinks the at
Poole you can only have two guests per
household oh [ __ ] we violated the
covenant but this email from the board
is still absurd right no it's not absurd
you just didn't do your homework you
didn't do your homework that's what
happened you didn't do your homework did
I just [ __ ] rip the spread here with
that pen in the back pocket laying on my
mother's [ __ ] quilt here um another
[ __ ] am I here I gotta go back to this
here by the way everybody thinks every
sound of my podcast is a fart no because
I hold this thing to my chest any
[ __ ] sound that's made oh you [ __ ]
ripped ass last week I mean maybe I did
I don't think I don't feel that I am
maybe I am I don't know um but it's I
mean I'm in my house you know I have to
fart I let it go you can't [ __ ] smell
it deal with it
no dude this is all on you this is just
he said but loud conversations what
drinking alcoholic beverages prior to
visiting the pool area are you kidding
me the police may be called get an F in
life dude dude this is their life this
is the end of their life and they want
quiet okay half of them probably fought
in [ __ ] wars the last thing I need is
you with your newfangled [ __ ] Elvis
music that is Jack Johnson to them look
it this is the deal you guys [ __ ] up
okay you guys [ __ ] up all right and
this is part of buying your first house
okay I bought my first house back in
2011 and you know what I was like wow
it's a great old house it has a lot of
character you know you know what my
[ __ ] old people at the pool was
galvanized pipes in the walls cloth
wiring a gas leak flashing when I turned
on the lights to possibly ignite the gas
underneath my [ __ ] house would rot
termites non-permitted [ __ ] building
[ __ ] I just you [ __ ] named it put a
new roof on it the guy [ __ ] up he
didn't reach the thing the water came
through they blamed me I just said [ __ ]
it I paid for it myself
this is part of it dude I'm really sorry
that you're going through this
I'm sure there's somebody else old that
will buy your [ __ ] house other than
that I would just you are in a communal
area I would be quiet when you go down
to the pool I mean I try to look at the
bright side at least nobody's gonna be
listening to loud [ __ ] Benny Goodman
music all the way into the night because
old people you know they fall asleep
like nine times a day so and even if you
don't like your neighbor they're gonna
die soon there's a lot of positive ways
to look at this and you can also you can
always sell so I would make the best of
it you can always over I would over I
would go out and go get [ __ ] hammered
and be loud in the young part of town
and then come back just make sure you
get some sort of electric car to cruise
you up real quietly to your [ __ ]
front door I'm sorry you're going
through that but what you learned is you
have to [ __ ] check out your
neighborhood before you you know you got
to read everything you know so that's
the deal all right I hope it works out
for you all right Oh guess who just text
me back this is why Jimmy door is the
[ __ ] because I just read [ __ ] and Jimmy
gets to the bottom but this is what
Jimmy just sent me back basically yes
the judge left opened the door for the
lawyers to refile in a way that would be
more successful the important thing in
this case is that the lawsuit forced the
dnc lawyer to admit in court that they
don't have to run a fair primary and
that they can pick and choose whoever
whoever they want and can ignore the
voters they can ignore the voters will
if they choose to do so the WikiLeaks
emails revealed that the DNC was
colluding with the Clinton campaign and
gave her an unfair advantage which is
why Wasserman Schultz resigned before
the DNC convention last summer the judge
dismissed the case it appears to me
based on the fact the plaintiff did not
have Stan standing to sue and the
federal court did not have jurisdiction
in this case I am interviewing the
lawyer who filed this case today so
hopefully lots will be cleared up in
that interview so there you go search
Jimmy door I'll send out a link to
that's a comedian that's that's an
in-form
guy here how that thing was written here
on eloquent that was I actually sounded
smart while reading that check that out
oh man oh my god oh my god all those
women who cried over [ __ ] Hillary
Clinton she's just as [ __ ] filthy as
this guy can you believe this Trump can
you [ __ ] believe this Trump that's
all you hear out and [ __ ] Hollywood
land where I live and it's just like I
want to it's true so I'd be like what do
you think about that and watch them
completely dismiss it the same way to go
back to Tom Brady well be alright so he
lets the cons here what they air out of
a ball what about when you guys did this
and that the other people root for the
ball that was no [ __ ] big deal
because our team did it I [ __ ] love
it I love it I love Jesus Christ do I
love it okay boss racist racist racist
question mark hey Billy booze bag ah
Billy no fun 11 days [ __ ] shut
up I know you're not drinking oh he got
me look at that anymore it's all I could
come up with all right bill recently our
company at an event where we give a tour
to possible clients who will partner
with us in the future during this event
our boss who was outgoing and funny was
ironing white sheets and thought it
would be funny to poke fun at the KKK by
placing a white sheet over his head and
saying black lives matter he immediately
recognized the situation took it off his
head and addressed the whole company the
next day he apologized and made our
counselors available to the company
forever was affected and offended jesus
[ __ ] christ you got to go through all
of that I just love these people that
are just so [ __ ] I don't know where
the [ __ ] they lived that they feel like
I can do this and they're not gonna have
a problem but then everybody's like so
[ __ ] hurt they need to be like
counseled aren't you just trying to get
out of your job for a couple hours just
walk up to the guy and say you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then if you want the
guy fired just say that someone's got to
sit there and hold your hand the only
problem was that he left out the black
lives matter part in the first meeting
and simply said oh wait a minute so when
I would he's saying okay wait a second
the only problem was that he left out
the black life lives matter part in the
first meeting and simply said he placed
the sheet over his head which is where
the outrage came from you know dude
that's one of the most important part
information most important information
in this [ __ ] story and you left out
some words here the only problem was
that he left out the black lives matter
part in the first meeting and simply
said he place the sheet over his head
which is where were wer e were the
outrage came from dude what am I
supposed to do with this in the council
meeting with everyone I couldn't help
but notice only white middle-aged women
were trashing the guy they were crying
etc not one minority in that room said
they were affected it pissed me off
because it was almost insulting to
minorities watching this what if there
was actually a minority who was actually
racially discriminated against and went
to court and wasn't listened to dude I
don't know what you're talking about
right now I'm 90% sure these women were
just looking for money it's not like our
boss tried to hide or make excuses so
the white women got offended what a this
is like a [ __ ] beat sheet for a
script that isn't written yet what white
middle-aged women were trashing the guy
they were crying etc that [ __ ]
sentence ended then he began a new
paragraph with that and then starts
talking about the minority women there I
don't know what you're talking about
here sir
ok so ok so you're asking me what ok one
of my opinions you think these women are
just looking for an opportunity to sue
sue SE w so for money or do you think
they actually believe these ladies were
offended thanks B I don't know what
you're talking about here sir I have no
idea I have no idea
I mean am I making fun of white women
for acting like they were offended and
crying cuz you think I have no idea I
don't know what sir proofread okay I'm
not a good speller either but you know I
do know where the spellcheck is and I
hit the button and it erases all my
impurities all right my fiancee isn't
into [ __ ] other men okay he says I
feel or she said I don't know what the
[ __ ] this is
what gender this is he said I feel like
this is a slightly different yet amusing
take on relationship issues and would
love to hear your tackle you tackle this
in a podcast basically I really like
watching my girl [ __ ] other men it's not
a cuckold thing because I'll [ __ ] her
right after and it's always the best sex
we ever had right after you don't have a
shower first sir right after okay hey
you know I don't judge whatever you want
to do if that's what you guys are in my
issue is that our sex is already great
and I'm well above average in size and
stamina so it's hard for her to find
another guy she's actually interested in
oh Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ you started all the way to
the left now we're all the way to the
right oh wow this guy this [ __ ] guy
here you know I don't mind I don't mind
her [ __ ] other guys I can handle it
because at the end of the day might get
so big nobody can follow me okay now I'm
judging the guy I don't know why I'm
doing this is just all over the [ __ ]
map I don't push the issue because I'm
confident in my abilities evidently so
confident you got to [ __ ] write an
email about it and don't want her to
have a bad time simply for my pleasure
but I wanted to know your opinion on the
subject we have threesomes with other
women god bless you and I can't even get
into them so I can't judge her I love
her and our amazing sex has been a
driving factor after almost four years
yet there's something about [ __ ] her
after she's been with another man that
is so hot to me I can't actually
accurately explain it and she just
doesn't seem into it because as she puts
it I do it better too
this is one of the greatest evening I
hope even if you just made this up I
would really appreciate your opinion on
this weird kind of relationship where
the issue for me is that I can't get off
because the girl as incredible as she is
is too perfect what where the issue for
me is that I can't get off because the
girl as incredible is she is is too
perfect so the way her to make her not
perfect just to have you watch your
[ __ ] other-- guy so you got a giant
dick and you enjoy it and you kind of
like wanna show like that is the only
way you can look at it this is like you
like the head like the best comedian in
the [ __ ] country alright but there's
still some level of insecurity you have
that you have to go on on these these
these shows where the comics aren't at
your level and you have to go on last
and you have to [ __ ] kill harder and
kill longer than anybody else to prove
that you are the best comedian in the
[ __ ] country if not the world it's
not the [ __ ] universe right is that
what it is is it the fact that you know
that you're [ __ ] nailing are better
than these these other [ __ ] guys they
come out with their average dicks and
their little [ __ ] dicks and she's
bored shitless do you make the other
people watch you know what I mean like
you're helping out their golf swing you
know you keep lifting your head you got
to [ __ ] keep your head down as you
follow through do it I don't know I
don't have the problems you have surf
alright
I am very follow ball I have no idea I I
do it I have no idea that is like I
would send that into can you please go
on dr. Phil because I just want to watch
him and see what goes on in his eyes
when he listens to this story where he
just goes like so you know
to have another man have sex with your
woman with the penile device that is
smaller than yours in order for you to
get all that's what you're saying and
you know dr. Phil's got some giant
ex-cop dick right you know he's got some
[ __ ] huge Hogan that's what you do
that's the end of the episode is you go
in the back and you watch dr. Phil [ __ ]
your wife with the sweat pouring off his
[ __ ] head and you're just sitting
there relaxed and confident right
you'd be funny he probably you probably
didn't get naked he just dropped his
pants down he'd still have his [ __ ]
wing tips on you know what he'd do to
try to beat you in an inter here in the
[ __ ] you know hit this dirty talk
would be how much [ __ ] money he's
worth he want to go to opens tonight huh
do you want to go to Oprah's tonight I
can make it happen that's I'm sorry I
know this is a [ __ ] up podcast but I
didn't I didn't I wasn't the one that
took it into that area all right other
people did that was really weird that
was a really weird visual the whole
thing was weird and who knew who the
[ __ ] knew who the [ __ ] knew that this
podcast would start as innocently as it
did talking about Hitler getting his
make-a-wish and would end so [ __ ] up
with whatever the [ __ ] it is I was just
describing all right that's the podcast
everybody please download the new Queens
of the Stone Age album please buy some
tickets to my show at the Surf ballroom
and it was a Clear Lake Iowa it's gonna
be a [ __ ] amazing night and what else
what else what else what else I'll post
those videos for you that's it and
congratulations everybody that rented
the fight and enjoyed it I don't know
ruin your [ __ ] time and I think
that's it I'll check in on you on
Thursday go [ __ ] yourselves